so Spider-Man across the spider-verse
feels like one of those comic book films
that stands as a milestone in the entire
genre after that seminal first film it
seemed like it couldn't be topped but
somehow this movie massively improves on
it in every single area I have to admit
that on my first watch though I thought
the First Act of the film was a bit slow
yeah there's a major turning point in
the movie where everything hits the fan
and it turns it up to 11. in retrospect
those early scenes are made even better
by what happens in this one and it just
brings the entire movie together to
cement the main themes of it now the
scene I'm talking about is of course the
chase scene in Nueva York that happens
at the midpoint of the movie throughout
this video we're going to be breaking
down the build up to it what happens in
the scene and also how it delivers on
the theme setup in those early moments
to knock it out the park
Stop Me Now
you can't run forever dude I can't lose
one more friend
no idea what are you doing everyone
keeps telling me how my story is
supposed to go nah
I'm gonna do my own thing
stations stop Spider-Man now before we
get to that bit I think we have to
discuss the themes established in the
film at the start so we can talk about
how they culminate here after the intro
with Gwen we joined miles roughly one
year on from the events of the first
film being Spider-Man has taken a toll
on his life and he's missing lessons at
school his parents parties and never
really present a defining scene in the
film mirrors one from the first movie in
which his teachers trying to map out
what he's going to be the first movie
had him working on a great expectations
paper whereas here is seen as being a
blank piece of paper the teacher wants
him to go and tell his story and Define
who he is rather than everyone else
pushing it on him now we learned that
miles wants to attend Princeton but his
parents just want him to stay home even
says to his father that he got to go and
start a business with his uncle Aaron
because he had a choice miles wants to
study and explore the Multiverse more
and Princeton seems to be the place
that's gonna allow him to do it however
everyone's trying to get him to do what
they want him to do and this is mirrored
in the spider society that we meet in
the movie after arriving at the
headquarters he gets a big tour of the
area and he meets the leader of the
group in magello horror dealing with the
fact he lost his surrogate family
through destroying an alternate reality
he's now bearing the weight of the world
all worlds on his shoulders he's bitter
angry and making the difficult decisions
in order to do what he sees is right
this comes with a cost though and it
means that certain people around every
Spider-Man and woman variant have to die
these Canon moments Define the character
and with Miles being a person whose
setup is someone who needs a path it
works on an extra level now Miguel also
works as a perfect opposite to Miles as
he shows how choosing the wrong path can
eat away at his soul even though he
reassures himself that they're the good
guys he can tell that he doesn't fully
believe it and he knows it's not a black
and white issue we of course have the
spot who's very black and white and how
he views everything and thematically it
works so well to have these two as the
movie's antagonists Miguel is another
person who's a pushy adult that's trying
to tell Miles what his story should be
whereas the teacher wanted miles to
Define himself Miguel and the other
spider peeps want to enforce what should
be Canon surrounding him almost like a
mob we get the idea that this is the
personification of peer pressure with
all them having accepted these
horrendous things have to happen because
that's what the rules are however miles
is an anomaly in this in that he refuses
to back down and accept the fat he's
been handed which involves the death of
his father we're told that every
Spider-Man has to have a close police
captain who dies in the line of duty
trying to save someone else and this is
something that's been seen throughout
every iteration of the character all the
way back in Amazing Spider-Man 90
Captain Stacy was killed and he did this
while saving a child from some falling
Rubble since then it's something that's
gone on to be adapted in all different
versions of the character with Andrew
Garfield's variant even taking Spotlight
in the film however it echoes throughout
eternity and it's something that's said
to be absolutely necessary Gwen has even
gone on to accept that her dad has to
die too but we see how miles's actions
actually a bit is for her come the end
of the film her dad decides to give up
the badge and this means that he won't
actually die in the line of duty now not
only has miles saved him but he's also
saved this archetype in the Spider-Man
into your Universe saw that had
disastrous consequences it still shows
that miles is going against the grain
and being someone who will save the
police captain that's obviously setting
things up with his father and Miles
being this anomaly extends to the plot
as well we discover that Miles was
actually never meant to be and that the
spot actually took the spider from Earth
42 through using the kingpin's collider
the Spider-Man at the stud of into the
spider-verse wasn't meant to die and
this only happened because miles got in
the way Miguel views miles as being
someone who shouldn't be and thus he's
an anomaly in not only autonomy but also
in terms of his Origins and that takes
us properly into the scene in which
miles refuses to let his dad die told
almost like a lecture we see Miguel
explaining how important it is that
things stay the same he wants to keep it
all as this status quo now things play
out like how they have a hundred times
before again miles goes against us
though and it very much represents the
purpose of the character in general
miles has brought in to change things up
and his introduction in the Ultimate
Universe was done to make that book
stand out from the rest in a Peter
Parker died and it was a bold move to do
something like this and then replace him
with Miles Brian Michael bendisk he
could have easily stuck to the status
quo but instead he took a chance and had
miles take over the Reigns though there
was backlash at the time Bend is stuck
to his guns and miles is now of course
an extremely popular character now I
also appreciate how even the themes of
this film are nods to his overall
creation miles is going against the
grain and refusing to conform and I
don't think it's any coincidence that
spider Punk is the person that he sides
with he's someone who represents not
doing what Society tells him to and
Miles choosing to heed his advice shows
he aligns with his punk attitude punk
and Miguel are sort of the angels and
Devils on miles's shoulder giving him
the choice of who to go and follow
although I'm trying to go very high
concept with it in the video and explain
stuff on an analytical level the scene
itself yeah just so cool in it
it's amazing absolutely loved it
watching miles escape the Sun and then
everything go crazy it just blew me away
and even though I knew this chase scene
was coming because of the trailers it
didn't prepare me for what I saw
everything is thrown at him and when the
spider cat attack happens I thought that
was as crazy as things were gonna get
when the T-Rex swung in
in hell and it just gets crazier and
crazier the more things go on miles is
Public Enemy Number One with thousands
of spider people rushing him as he
barely makes it through by the skin of
his teeth you've got the amazing Bag Man
going for him chibi Spider-Man in one of
the corners the Western one trying to do
an impromptu draw and one in a
wheelchair dropping crutch jokes before
we hit the 1960s one it's one of those
scenes that feels like you're gonna have
to watch a hundred times in order to see
everything and it shows how rich of a
history that Spider-Man has all these
variants have appeared at some point and
to see them celebrate on screen like
this feels like something else just
ramps up the chase even more and we get
a bit of a breather when miles is pulled
aside by Peter B telling him that he was
the reason he wanted to have a child you
can see how miles has had such a
positive impact man gets told he's a
terrible Mentor but miles has turned out
pretty good in the grand scheme of
things and a Peter B are still bloody
like you now we realize that Pina B has
been used as a way to track miles and
thus he has to die through some spinning
cylinders in order to get away yeah the
spider is dropping off while's miles
slips through could represent how he's
managed to make it pass you the very
instead of dropped in the pop cultures
like Geist
the Chase comes to a head when we watch
Miles making his way to a train
traveling upwards right into the
stratosphere told that he's not really a
Spider-Man by Miguel we hear him say I
am Miles Morales I was bitten by a
radioactive spider this is something
that's used to open up lots of
Spider-Man comics it was used by Chris
Pratt in the first film hey there
everybody this is Chris Pine and it
shows just how much that he's taken over
the role Miguel but writes him though
and explains that he's not really a true
Spider-Man and that he's just a kid who
doesn't know what he's doing held on his
back and seemingly bit in Miles reveals
that he actually does know what he's
doing and that he's LED all the spider
peeps away so that he can return to the
base at this point we get an incredible
monologue that builds up everything
we've talked about before and and it
just goes to show why miles is this
incredible person miles jumps off the
train taking a metaphorical leap of
faith and this builds off the back of
the first film finally he realizes that
he's gonna be his own person and that'll
create his own story rather than being
dictated to him rather than sticking to
the script or just becoming another
Spider-Man variant Mars is becoming his
own man and this is something that's
been seen in the real world too miles
could have easily become just another
bug standard take on the character but
he's elevated himself much further
beyond that finally he's getting the
respect he deserves and showing why he
should be viewed as a valid character
works on so many levels and not only the
film but also in the real world too and
it knocks it out the park which is why I
think the scene is perfect obviously let
me know your thoughts on it in the
comment section below is there anything
else you took from it and what did you
think of the movie as a whole you want
to support the channel for as little as
99 cents a month then please click the
join button below and as a thank you
you'll get early access to videos every
week you also have our merch store over
at xeroedition.com and this sells lots
of different things like t-shirts hats
and more we just launched a secret
Invasion slash Pulp Fiction inspired
so head over there and help us out
if you want to support the channel now
if you want something else to watch then
we have a video on screen right now
going over every single vocal Cameo that
appears in the film definitely recommend
it if there's anything you think you
missed in the movie which you might have
because let's be honest it's packed and
yeah thanks for sticking through the
video up until this point I've been your
host Paul you've been the best and I
hope that you enjoy the rest of your
weekend you take care peace
[Music]